The defense rests in
the Alex Murdaugh murder trial.
Attorneys for Murdaugh.
What's prominent
attorney accused of killing his wife
and son
called their final witnesses today,
including Murdaugh's brother
broke down while describing
how he cleaned up the blood soaked
crime scene once police left.
Diane Gallagher is OUTFRONT
Thanks for your honor.
The defense
resting its case in the Alex
Murdaugh double murder trial
with its final witnesses today.
The defense
calling to experts to the stand,
trying to poke holes
and create doubt around the state's
timeline of what happened
the night of June seven
when Maggie and Paul Murdaugh
were killed.
A pathologist
questioning how the time of death
was initially calculated
by the county coroner.
By far,
the best, best methodology
is to do a core body temperature
and an ambient temperature
and an ambient temperature. Yes.
So tell me what you would learn
by sticking your hand
under the armpit of a deceased.
You wouldn't learn anything
of that impression.
And a crime scene analyst,
the individual who shot first
with the shotgun man, Emily was stunned.
Probably bloody material in his eyes.
And maybe he'd been injured
and would have taken some degree of time
to recover.
Once again, floating the defenses
to shooter theory.
To me, there's
structurally difficult
for the same shooter to have two arms
and no practical reason
for that to happen.
Add that to what I believe happened
to the shooter
who fired first with the shotgun
and I think
it tips in favor
of the probability of two shooters.
The state pushing back.
And you referred to Paul being shot
in the back of the head,
kind of like an explosion.
Correct.
And I'm not a physicist or anything here.
But when you fire a shotgun,
things are going
in a direction
that the gun is fired, right? Correct.
So there wouldn't be just like a boom
explosion, like from a bomb.
Shotgun.
Actually,
that's more exactly
what it would be like. Yes.
I read the whole
closing out the day
and the defense's case,
emotional testimony
from the final witness,
Alex Murdaugh's younger brother,
John Marvin Murdaugh,
who testified
about cleaning the crime scene
the next day.
Y'all can imagine what I experienced.
It had not been cleaned up as cold
blood as old brains are.
So pieces of skull
or in
when I say brains,
it could just be tissue.
I don't know what it was.
It was just it was terrible.
But during cross-examination,
the prosecution called back
to Alex Murdaugh's own testimony
when he admitted to lying
about being at the kennels
before the murders happened there.
Would you agree
that that is not full cooperation by him
not telling SLED
that he was at the kennel? Correct.
I would say that, yes, he lied
Now, the jury is actually going
to be leaving the courtroom,
taking a trip
to Moselle, the Murdaugh family property
where the murders happened.
The judge granted
the defense's request
for the visit today.
But before any of that happens,
the state still has its rebuttal
period, Erin.
The prosecutor
saying their plan to call four
to five witnesses tomorrow.
All right, Diane, thank you very much.
She's been covering this trial from
the very beginning.